the train arriving on this platform is
from poland but many of the people on
board are fleeing the war in ukraine
reaching berlin by rail has taken many
hours some are tired and disorientated
by the journey all are grateful to have
reached safety
maria was a student in
when the russians invaded they bombed my
university
that day that we left so it's like very
sad i think we really like it that we
have friends here
and we have like
the home where we can live
for now vincent was at college in
bilatserkfar when the war began now safe
in germany he's hoping to resume
i can his
admitted into school i can
cool down my head and continue my
studies and make the best out of myself
yes i'm confident i can because
one good thing is that
people here they are friendly
and
it will give me an age to adapt to the
environment as quick as possible the
welcome being provided to the refugees
is by volunteers as is the food and
drink those are all donations those are
all donations for people
this is not from from from the republic
or from the government this is all just
private people
the city's mayor has appealed for help
processing so many refugees on monday
afternoon she and the federal interior
minister came to see the situation for
themselves
not everybody here is leaving the war
zone this woman is traveling to it with
bulletproof vests for those on the front
line
although the vast majority of people
fleeing ukraine have not tried to reach
germany it's estimated that tens of
thousands of refugees have got here
since the war began
many more may arrive here in the coming
days
dominic kane al jazeera berlin